[Music]  thank you  [Music]  let that your out  this will prepending  [Music]  I will hold you  and protect you  you so let love  warn you  'd sail the more  [Music]  I'll stay  with you  by your side  close your tired and I'll wait  I'll see your smile  [Music]  smile in Her Dream Baby  [Music]  don't worry  it's okay  I'll always be with you  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  don't worry  it's okay  no one should have to suffer such loss  you know I meant that when I said I  understand how you feel or if you hold  on to the sadness it'll wave down like  an anchor  commit my gruesome  thank you  and start a new Journey  it wasn't the UCA that made the final  decision  it was APAC a private Corporation  so let love warn you  till the morning  well